the aftershocks shuddered through the
foundation emergency alarms wailed as
injured staff and security helped each
other out from underneath Rubble that
had fallen on them as the building was
shaken by the Quake it had only lasted a
few short seconds but still managed to
leave a trail of Destruction in its wake
while the wounded were bandaged up
anyone and everyone who was still able
to started frantically checking the
containment of every anomaly on the site
the foundation could worry about the
origin of the Quake later first and
foremost they needed to assess the
damage luckily multiple rapid sweeps of
the facility revealed that there weren't
all that many high-level threat
anomalies whose containment had been
breached a few of the safer ones were
found cowering under tables or buried
under Fallen Rubble in their quarters
but for the most part every anomaly was
accounted for and none had been provided
with an opportunity to escape and cause
for their Havoc at least that's how
things seemed at first it was only when
the k tail started to die down and
repair efforts were underway that
Personnel noticed an odd change
something was missing but nobody could
quite put their finger on exactly what
as a matter of fact most could pinpoint
exactly when they noticed this odd
feeling it had only begun after the
emergency alarms had been shut off there
was a sound that everyone working at the
foundation had gotten so used to that
they practically stopped hearing it or
at least they'd stopped noticing it it
was only now that the noise was gone its
absence no longer drowned out by blaring
alarms that staff realized it had always
been there everyone had just learned to
subconsciously tune it out crying the
low soft whimpering that could be heard
emanating from
scp-096's containment chamber it had
stopped the cell within had fallen
silent and once someone at the
foundation made the right connection and
investigated they happened on a
startling Discovery
scp-096 had vanished Panic immediately
engulfed the facility yet again the shy
guy could be anywhere and a search
effort to find it would only end in
deaths after all in order to find
something you have to look at it and
that was a fatal thing to do when
scp-096 was involved closer examination
showed no trace of the missing creature
there had been no reported incidents of
incursions with it anywhere in the world
every known photograph video recording
or other visual depiction of scp-096 was
either securely stashed away or
destroyed completely by the foundation
there was no way it could have possibly
escaped and it was seemingly nowhere at
all but still the question remained
where in the world had the shy guy gone
to if it was still even in this world
from scp-096's perspective one moment
all had been normal the next it was lost
somewhere strange unfamiliar and above
all unsettling even to the shy guy
before the sudden Quake had hit it had
spent the day the same way it usually
occupied its time alternating between
aimlessly pacing the far wall of its
containment chamber and sitting in a
fetal position in the corner sobbing all
the while but then the room had started
shaking and in the blink of a deeply
sunken eye the shy guy found itself
while it had no idea where around it was
a large carpeted room open and sparse
with little occupying all the space the
wallpaper was a nauseating sickly shade
of yellow made all the more garish by
the rows of fluorescent lighting from
the ceiling above the entire Place
seemed to resemble an office space
although seemingly one that was in a
total state of disuse there was no
furniture not even one solitary
inanimate object to make the place seem
at least the tiniest bit closer to
normal little was scp-096 aware it had
somehow been transported to a a strange
and terrible place the back rooms unless
someone remains wary and ever Vigilant
they can unknowingly slip their way out
of reality it can happen anywhere all
that a person needs to do is be in the
wrong place at the wrong time and they
will no clip into the back rooms all
around scp-096 was the stench of old wet
carpet and a Labyrinth of uninhabited
rooms with the same drab yellow walls
the endless Buzz of the fluorescent
lights stretching out for who knows how
many square miles of empty rooms in
short the shy guy was trapped in a
purgatory-like nightmare however there
was at least one small Mercy for scp-096
as it wandered around its new
surroundings there was nobody else
around no other signs of life no SCP
Foundation No Ordinary human beings no
one who could see it here in the
solitary confinement of the back rooms
scp-096 could not be perceived and yet
this brought the self-conscious creature
very little in the way of comfort
despite being completely alone there was
an awful lingering feeling that hung in
the air like the smell of the old carpet
underfoot
scp-096 still felt like it was being
watched and yet if someone or something
really was watching it wasn't triggering
the Shy Guy's usual rage State as it
lurked through the various rooms and
corridors the creature kept expecting to
find someone to look them in the eye
directly and get the same inescapable
urge to race towards its Observer and
kill them but it never came because
there was nobody else around at least
for a little while Adam Jenkins had been
out riding his bike when it happened
pushing one pedal around then the other
he gradually climbed higher up the slope
of a hill his house was down at the
bottom of the other side and Adam knew
once he reached the peak he could slip
nice and easily down the rest of the way
as long as he was careful not to let the
extra momentum carry his bike too far
and too fast he just had to keep in
control and gently compress the brake if
he needed to he made the same Journey
every day nothing could go wrong sure
enough Adam reached the top of the hill
and allowed the bike to slowly tip ever
so slightly over the other side gravity
started to do the rest the wheels
starting to spin rapidly the pedals
pistoning his legs as he plummeted
downwards he was one of the few
childlike Joys left in Adam's life those
few brief seconds of the day where he
got to speed down the hill back home
with Reckless abandon it was blissfully
unaware that he wouldn't have enough
time to miss how much he enjoyed it
without warning a car came speeding out
from around a corner on the way down the
hill it was dark and the driver had
carelessly decided to leave their
headlights off so when Adam saw the
vehicle he only had a split second to
react he was still going too fast so if
he applied the brakes now his front
wheel would stop too suddenly and sent
him flying forward over the handlebars
instead seconds before colliding with
the car's Hood Adam wrenched his bike's
handlebars and swerved around the car
but the added speed of going downhill
caused the entire bike to topple as it
turned so violently launching at him off
and sending him hurtling towards a
nearby wall Adam could tell in the Split
Second after coming off his bike that he
was about to collide with the wall his
brain and body anticipated the impact
bracing him for the painful crash but it
never came instead of hitting the wall
Adam passed through it that may well
have spared him a devastating injury but
now a whole new problem now faced him
just like no clipping through a virtual
environment in a video game Adam had
passed directly out of reality right
into the back rooms the first few hours
were the worst shouting as loud as he
could for someone anyone to come and
find him each yell rapidly growing more
and more frantic as Adam rushed around
his haunting news surroundings the whole
place wasn't settling just to be in it
gave off a hostile unwelcoming energy
that was impossible to ignore it was
only after an hour of trying to find a
way out that Adam realized he was well
and truly lost he'd strayed too far away
from his original point of entry and
just as he had the idea of trying to
make his way back to the world from the
same place he came in it was already too
late the back rooms at least on this
first level all looked the same no two
rooms were distinct enough for him to
figure out if this was somewhere he'd
been before or an entirely new area it
didn't take long for an overwhelming
sense of hopelessness to set in Adam had
quickly given up calling for help there
was no sign of anyone around that would
be able to help him until the shuffling
of footsteps came from nearby it was
such a noticeable break in the dull
unsettling quiet of the back rooms that
it made Adam's ears prick up the yellow
cued maze had been so void of life since
he had arrived so unnaturally empty that
he wasn't entirely sure he had made the
sound himself by his jacket brushing up
against the wall but no there was
definitely something here with him he
could hear it wandering nearby and it
had certainly hurt him too calling out
yet again with more caution in this tone
Adam Jenkins turned the next Corner met
with yet another dingy yellow Corridor
although unlike the others this one had
a key difference
scp-096 stood right in the middle of it
the split second that Adam's eyes fell
over the shy guy who was already too
late he barely had time to process the
side of the creature its tall humanoid
shape wiry thin and pale skin jaw
hanging unnaturally wide in fact
scp-096 dashed towards Adam so quickly
that he couldn't even finish his
startled scream meanwhile back at the
SCP Foundation efforts were still
underway to retrieve the shy guy
researchers were baffled that there was
not a single trace anywhere on the globe
of scp-096's presence they had quickly
rolled out their usual method for
recalling the creature to containment
requisitioning one of d-class personnel
this individual was instructed to stand
in
scp-096sl and then was given a
photograph of the monster to look at
knowing that the shy guy would track
down anyone that saw its face even as a
single tiny pixel in a picture the
foundation expected the creature to
Simply reappear in its containment
chamber to kill the d-class they had
used as bait but nothing happened the
d-class was able to look at the photo of
scp-096 and survive it was almost as if
the creatures linked to reality was
weakened wherever it was it might still
be aware someone had looked at it but
the shy guy was somehow being blocked
from traveling to its most recent
Observer having drawn a blank on trying
to determine scp-096's whereabouts the
foundation eventually turned to scp-343
for his input naturally the powerful
reality vendor was reluctant as ever to
get involved the foundation insisted
knowing that scp-343's omniscience meant
he would already be aware of where they
could find the missing shy guy he
refused multiple times admitting he did
have the answer they were looking for
but not wishing to divulge that
information fine
scp-343 side coming to a compromise I
can't tell you exactly where zero nine
six is but when I tell you where to look
for answers you'll know async the
researchers were stunned into silence
nobody in the foundation had heard that
name used in a long time but scp-343 was
right they knew exactly what it meant
back in the 1980s async was another
shadowy organization that had been
investigating the existence of a liminal
space connected to reality a place they
had called the back rooms Gathering up a
mobile task force the SCP Foundation
dispatched its agents to a site that had
long since been abandoned they'd kept a
watchful AI over the disused lab keeping
the public away making sure nobody
stumbled in by accident and got trapped
as the MTF Commander gave the word the
outdated 80s technology was fired up and
async's great achievement was
reactivated they had constructed a
portal into the back rooms moving
information the MTF operatives filed
into the empty yellow space unsure if
they'd find scp-096 alive or if it would
even want to come back meanwhile in the
back rooms level zero only the shy guy
remained having completely annihilated
Poor Unfortunate Adam he was enjoying
the Solitude once again knowing that now
nobody was here to see him until one
wrong step changed everything he no
clipped from Level zero to level one
where he would have a lot more company
now go and check out scp-096 versus
scp-343 and scp-096 versus scp-106 for
more